[Musique]
je suis réunionnaise et c'est ma
fierté vivre en échange un mélange une
union un
métissage qui perdure dans l'âge
on vit ce CTI de couleur aucune
différence religion main dans la main et
cultivons cet
[Musique]
entant habite tous ensemble sans
préjugés ni discrimination unis
ou toutes les origines se
m nous avons tous la même couleur de
sang une image de
solidarité d'opinion partagée un sens de
vie qui nous
hum réunion une terre de culture et
d'art divers un métissage un voyage cœur
du monde un savoir de vivre
ensemble nous toutes les là ensemble n'a
point dispute N a la paix nous l' un
exemple pour le monde regarde comment
nous vivent ici en
partage peu importe la couleur nous les
blancs jaunes noirs nous toutes les
frères et sœurs vivre ensemble ici il
prend tout son
sens ne laissons pas la haine nous
ronger vivons le temps présent le cœur
rempli de tolérance de respect soyons
tous
ég soyons unis montrons au monde que nos
religions et nos origines restent une
belle couleur et un mélange qui nous
ressemble arrête vivre dans la peur n la
place pour tout de N un seul cœur un
seule nation un seu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
couleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]